in Washington Republicans are all set to
take control of the house but their
leader Kevin McCarthy is being forced to
make some big concessions to right-wing
members of the party in his bid to
become house Speaker it could be a sign
of things to come as Republicans prepare
to turn up the heat on President Biden
Scott McFarland is on Capitol Hill for
us Scott Happy New Year good morning to
you good morning Ed Republicans have
pledged aggressive oversight and
investigations of the Biden
Administration but first they have to
end this standoff inside their own party
over who will be the next U.S House
speaker Kevin McCarthy of California
will spend the next 24 hours trying to
secure the necessary votes to become
speaker but even after a late Sunday
phone call with colleagues and
concessions to conservatives it doesn't
appear McCarthy has the votes yet
potentially setting the stage tomorrow
for drama on the house floor Republicans
have such a narrow majority the margins
will be particularly slim for this vote
one of the votes he might need is from
New York's George Santos the embattled
congressman elect who's accused of lying
about key parts of his life including
his education his work history claiming
his grandparents survived the Holocaust
he's also facing questions about how he
came into the money to help fund his
campaign there have been calls from some
of his soon-to-be colleagues for Santos
to step aside or undergo an Ethics
investigation but Santos has pledged to
serve his full two-year term so far
house leadership hasn't commented on
Santos but Ed you better believe they'll
face more questions when they return
here today
yeah and they're going to need his vote
because to be clear critical 24 hours
ahead for Kevin McCarthy in his bid to
become house Speaker does not yet have
the vote Scott McFarland will be
tracking it all for us on Capitol Hill
thank you